joining us on the line is dr. J
Bhattacharya he's a professor of
medicine at Stanford University research
associate at the National Bureau of
economics research senior fellow at the
Stanford Institute for Economic Policy
Research and at the Stanford Freeman
spogli Institute and he also directs the
Stanford center on demography of Health
and Ageing he has a piece in The Wall
Street Journal over the last couple of
days talking about the actual death rate
from kova Denine teen dr. Dre thanks so
much for joining the show really
appreciate it my pleasure
so let's talk about your piece the
initial estimate of the death rate on
kovat 19 were extraordinarily high we
heard from the World Health Organization
the same organization that screwed this
thing up I believe in China when they
said there was no human to human
transmission say that the death rate on
covin 19 was 3 to 4% which of course is
like Black Plague type stuff in the it's
the sort of thing where you start
thinking okay tens of millions of people
are going to die especially when
combined with the infection rate which
apparently is extraordinarily high
you've examined the statistics and what
you say is that the death rate is
actually exorbitantly low or at least
exorbitant Leeloo based on the the
original estimates how do you come to
that conclusion so Ben let me let me
explain that a little bit about the
scientific uncertainty here because I
think it's really important understand
so the three percent number and a lot of
those high numbers come from something
called a case fatality rate the case
fatality rate that has a numerator and
denominator numerator is the number of
people who die from Kovach that's a hard
number very very easy to see and measure
the denominator should be the number of
people who have been exposed to kovat
got the disease the problem the problem
is that when you measure the number of
people who've got the disease the test
people use and that what everyone's used
up to now being legit for scientific
reasons it haven't been a good test an
alternate test is a is a is a testament
RNA content of your to see if you
actually have the virus actively in you
but what if you get better what if you
get the color then you get better well
then the virus is gone and that test
would be negative so the denominator and
we also use these tests clinic in a way
to focus on people who have the disease
help clinic up there you're looking to
think I mean completely reasonably but
if you put those things together you
with the denominator that focuses on
people who have the virus and ignores
the people who don't who got the virus
and now have antibodies to it and at the
top and probably immune so what you
really want for the death rate is in the
denominator both of those populations
people who actively have the virus plus
people who have the virus and are
cleared cleared of it so that's why I
think that it's likely that that's we
three point four percent number the
World Health Organization out is put out
is is a is probably too high the central
key piece if it's missing scientific
information is this is what something
called the zero prevalence that the
proportion of the population that had
antibodies to the virus if we had that
number we could know the true death rate
and we could know how extensively the
virus spread it's already spread very
very extensively oh I'm sorry go ahead
oh no and you mentioned also that when
it comes to the number of people
measured there's also just that the lack
of testing generally means that there
are tons of people who are walking
around who may in fact have it under
asymptomatic but have not showed up for
a test so we're missing a couple of
numbers we're missing the people who
have recovered and have the antibodies
and we're also missing the people who
are walking around symptom free and
transmitting this thing because those
people aren't getting tested at all in
most places yeah no that's exactly right
I mean so both are absolutely sources of
error in the denominator of that number
we have to have that denominator for
rational policy because there's two
possibilities and with it with the data
I've seen and they produce very
radically different but correct optimal
policy response along on the one side
you have a disease that's incredibly
deadly but only if it you know
relatively few people have it then you
have an incredible long shutdown to
avoid making so that it extends to
everybody else that might be reasonable
on the other hand you have a disease
it's very very widespread and as deadly
like the flu or maybe less than the flu
and of course the problem is not you
there's no vaccine so you can't prevent
lots of people from getting it but but
on the other hand shut down in that
situation is probably less likely to be
the right policy response that you want
targeted things where people are
vulnerable you hold them you know you
keep you quarantine them or you provide
them support you make sure the hospital
systems don't get overwhelmed it's a
very different policy response
the key number that decides between
those two scenarios is the serie
problems in the population well we what
we desperately need right now is testing
for of what that number is in the
population level study of the antibody
testing the part to find out what the
serial problem says to decide between
those two scenarios
well one of the things that happened
today I know if you saw this is that the
the UK actually announced that they no
longer consider a cover 19 to be a high
consequence infectious disease
specifically because they are seeing the
death rate is significantly lower than
they thought it was so in your estimate
when we talk about what the actual death
rate is based on sort of the incomplete
data that we have are we talking about a
disease that is about as deadly as the
flu is it less deadly than the flu is it
multiple times more deadly than that for
what do you think is the range of
possibilities here I mean I I think I my
apophysis is it's less deadly than the
flu in order I don't know for that for a
fact it's a hypothesis and because I
don't know the number I don't know this
you know once I know this air of
problems I can answer that question with
a lot of certainty the people that say
that it's 3.4% they also don't know that
number and they're acting on you know
people say based on their expertise that
I know it's one number the other I don't
I don't feel comfortable with that
because they don't know that no
scientific study is done and looked at
that number so the question is how do we
respond now I am I based on what I have
the numbers that I've looked at and
based on my analysis I believe that it's
very likely a widespread disease and
much less deadly than and less than
anonymous or some was and someone must
have on average although obviously it's
killing killing people lots of people in
stressing hospital systems around the
world so it's nothing to take lightly
so the I think the keys the key way to
convince people that that is let's do
the science let's actually conduct the
population serious surveillance and for
that we're going to need to get rid of
lots of hurdles so like the FDA only
last couple of weeks or I think last
week maybe two we can have to go approve
the first antibody test for use in the
United States we need to expand our
capacity antibody test very very rapidly
and apply the
intelligent ways at the very first you
should be to let scientists who want to
measure the seer problems let us do it
well with all this said dr. J
Bhattacharya professor of medicine at
Stanford University let's say that your
hypothesis is correct and the death rate
is significantly lower than certainly
has been estimated and may be lower than
the flu so what would that look like in
terms of policy so the sort of going
know the going suggestion has been that
we needed a mass lockdown in the absence
of data so that we could determine
exactly what the rights are and so that
we didn't overwhelm our healthcare
system because obviously everybody seen
the flattening the curve chart at this
point and the curve being flattened
beneath what our healthcare system can
actually tolerate would be would be
necessary at this point we've seen no
estimates from the federal or state
governments as to how many beds ICU beds
how many ventilators would be necessary
where we feel secure and letting buddies
sort of out of isolation at this point
except for extraordinarily vulnerable
populations number one do you think that
the mass lockdown was the proper policy
in the absence of data number two given
that the massive lockdown has already
taken place how exactly would you
approach alleviation of that lockdown
what steps would you take in the in the
near future in order to get people back
to work if it turns out of your
hypothesis is correct that the death
rate is significantly lower than
expected identify first question I guess
I don't really have too much time for
recriminations at this point I do think
that we should that going forward think
much more carefully about how how we
make these decisions because I think to
some extent fear led to decisions that
have led to the shutdown I think there's
no shutdown on the other side we'll have
an illness consequence and I'm looking
at does unemployment rates that are just
on and out you know great depression
level and I don't I think that their
mortality effects of that as well so I
think one of the key things I would like
to see reformed is to is to
systematically appreciate the not just
visible consequences of like you know
people dying prove it it's visible
people reasonably want to stop do
something about that though so that the
invisible things that happen later as a
result of policy I because I believe
there's likely to be excess deaths
substantial numbers of them among the
poor or the elderly among lots of
honorable popular
as a result of the depression that I
think we're about date about to hit but
again that's that's for I think I'm for
later time right now the key the key
question is what seroprevalence and I
think once we know that and we can then
we can start to relieve the shutdown if
it is as high as I believe it's likely
to be we can start to relieve the
shutdown we can also use the testing as
a way to see if you can you can go back
to work my old my own professor who
wrote a really nice piece about this
Alan Garber what he's basically argues
is that look we can use zero zero
antibody testing say if your antibody
positive for probably immune go back to
work
yeah there's no risk of you from kovat
no risk of spreading it and so we can
end the shutdown right there
intelligently by systematically letting
people go back to work who not that's
you know spreading the disease in any
way shape or form an immune from the
need to it already and so I think those
kinds of ideas would be really really
useful going going forward so we can
sort of balance the epidemiology and the
economics in the right way because right
now the policy is a complete shutdown is
going to have consequences on the other
side and people have characterises
dollars versus people don't you know
deaths but that's not really right it's
death on both sides you know if you have
an economic depression people are going
to die so I think I think that's the
right way to start to thinking about
this but but but let's do recriminations
later right now let's focus on getting
the right number we need which is the
Sarah problem and they're trying to use
the antibody testing in a way that
intelligence we allows it intelligently
allows us to expand to relieve the
shutdown get our economy going yet we're
speaking with dr. Jay Bhattacharya
professor of medicine at Stanford
University so I know that we don't wanna
do recommendations here dr. Jay but when
when we talk about the the lockdown and
and the the entire economy shut down one
of the suggestions is made by the
Imperial College study that suggested
that half a million people were gonna
die in the UK they've now estimated that
down to 20,000 or less in the UK over
the course of you know three days the
people who are in charge of the study
basically suggested the reason for that
that is number one the death rate being
lower but number two that the lockdown
is actually effective at preventing this
you let people out of the lockdown it's
not gonna be 20,000 maybe it's a hundred
thousand there's a study that came out
from University of Washington today
suggesting that the total number of
deaths in the United States over the
next four months could be 80,000 I'm not
sure what death rates they're applying
in that study I've been trying to figure
that out all day long here do you think
that the lockdown and people staying
home has been effective in at least
reducing the transmission how many
excess deaths have actually been
prevented and I'm not looking for you
know a hard number but like I said I
can't give you a hard number on this
which is difficult right but I think the
key thing there is that you can see the
uncertainty in practice right right in
front of you the arguments for the
shutdown essentially is to not overwhelm
health care systems it's like you guys
in Italy is what's happened in Italy
that's actually not unreasonable I mean
it depends on what turns on the capacity
of the healthcare system to deal with
large numbers of people who need
ventilators and ICU beds and things like
that so I think that it's hard to hear
me say my comment directly I think I
have paid very careful attention of the
Imperial College studies study and then
I saw just this morning but Neil
Ferguson the PI that study just just
basically changed his mind it sounded
like that to look more carefully I think
there that that's that I mean there you
see people putting numbers in the
seroprevalence essentially they've
assumed that zero prevalence and death
rate number initially that led to this
massive massive shut down policy but
that number isn't justified by an actual
study and will pop up the population
they guess that number I mean I think we
just need you much more careful about
about and more humble I think about you
know the confidence with which we say
let's do this when we when we don't
actually know a number we should be we
should say we don't know that number at
or reflects the uncertainty in our in
our or confidence in our statements much
more more effectively and we typically
do and dr. Jay final question for you
let's assume that we actually do get
these tests in place that we start
running all of these SERO prevalence
test that that put zero prevalence by
the way just to check my definition of
this to make sure I'm getting this right
that would be checking the prevalence of
the of the antibodies in people's blood
basically once those once that once
those tests are correct then how soon do
you think this lets up how soon could we
could we be looking at getting out of
getting out of I want to bail yesterday
I want these tests yesterday I want them
done yesterday
I want the number immediately I and we
have studies that I'm working on with
some of my colleagues to get the Santa
Clara Valley and in LA County took it to
get Sarah Palin so it's not easy but we
need a nationwide study and we need
support for a nationwide study media but
the keys the two key things that are
missing right now is we need a large
number of antibody tests and we need
some funding source to pay for that test
and then we can get those we can get
that running with the whole I mean the
scientific community around the folks
I'm talk with they want these numbers
also so this is not something that's
controversial I don't think it's
partisan I just think it's we just need
we need the number and I'm hoping we'll
know it in two weeks done that the
latest well really amazing amazing stuff
in an interesting vital stuff here from
dr. Jay Bhattacharya professor of
medicine to Stan for really appreciate
your time sir and thanks so much for
your hard work on this topic
oh yeah thank you man is a little real
pleasure take care
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content